the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so today I'll talk about coin join
signature aggregation sort of well
before that privacy but privacy coin
join clone shuffle signature aggregation
and how these all connect it's a little
bit of a leap to put these boats in the
same class but not really they're there
they're connected but there are some
somewhat separate things today talk
about privacy coin join and various ways
to do that and then aggregate signatures
so Schnoor multi signatures and then
aggregation and attacks on this system
okay so the idea is privacy and there's
a bunch of terms we can use here like
anonymity and fungibility and whatever
the term for this I don't need any
because I have nothing to hide so I
don't need any privacy I don't need any
anonymity I'm a good person I don't
break the law I'm boring guy I don't do
anything crazy I'm joking but no I'm not
joking about being boring and not doing
anything crazy that is actually pretty
true I mostly just work on this stuff
but yeah that's a fairly common thing
that people say and the biggest thing
that sort of clearest example is it
won't have anything to hide you don't
have any Bitcoin because like literally
if you don't hide your private key and
someone will just immediately take your
bitcoins so so you do have secrets right
your secret is your private key and your
password and if bitcoin and these types
of systems really take off potentially
most of your money and a lot of your
wealth could be tied up in what is you
know a secret so if you're not able to
keep your secrets you could lose a lot
of money and larger like I sort of think
that going for you know this is very
sort of thought leader II future kind of
thing but going forward it seems like
sort of all you have is your secrets to
the extent that you can own anything the
thing that you really have control over
got these things in my head that no one
else knows and I might not you know
maybe I own my car but that's also sort
of property rights and legal systems and
maybe it can get repossessed maybe I own
this Lane
but again that's sort of this thing with
the state but I definitely really have
the stuff in my head and I can at least
you know try to keep keep that so even
if you think you have nothing to hide
you do have your private keys to hide
and that's sort of the obvious one but
but larger you want privacy because in
general you don't want to reveal stuff
about your coins this is you know
specific to Bitcoin but like my
philosophy is I generally don't want to
reveal stuff ever and a lot of times it
stores I remember like RadioShack when
it was still a thing and I was in like
high school they would always ask you
your phone number when you bought
anything and when I was little I would
just tell them my parents phone number
at my house cuz like I don't know they
asked but then once I was in like
college I was like wait no I'm just
gonna make something up and and now I do
that all the time and it sometimes gets
a million for other people because I
would like go to a restaurant they ask
you know I put my name down I'll say I'm
Fred and then my other friend comes and
she was like wait you're not listed like
and then she put her name in and like no
no no I'm already there I'm Fred and you
know like confusing things like that and
I hope and I horse sort of think that
that we're starting to see this kind of
thing like there's like facebook
hearings now and people are all shocked
that like the company Facebook can read
everyone's messages and see everything
well yeah that's how it works right
you're giving it all to their servers so
so I think it's starting to be like
we're before companies would all be like
we just want to get all the user data
possible hopefully going forward data
will be seen more as a liability and
less as an asset it means we're not
there yet
right because the companies who get sort
of hacked and lose all this user data
don't really get punished
so like the Equifax thing and like all
these different data breaches there's
not a ton of consequences yet maybe
there will be in the future and maybe
companies will start to like not want
all this data but you know it's it's
it's not as clean-cut as like well I
have no I didn't do anything wrong so I
don't want to hide it
sort of default hide is my stance and
there's and there's so many conflicting
interests where every time you're on the
websites it's like this website wants to
your location any like wait how do I
always disable that I don't I don't know
no the settings but everyone wants this
stuff so another reason especially you
know specifically in the case of money
is what's called fungibility and sounds
like a weird word it just means that
every Bitcoin is the same or every
dollar is the same right so dollars are
fungible in that you know physically
okay this twenty dollar bill and this
twenty dollar bill are worth the same
and different denominations so I will
give you a twenty four to ten and anyone
will do that they're worth the same you
don't have sort of well this dollars not
worth quite as much and sometimes that
happens right even with dollar bills
like when in other countries when the
new hundred dollar I think in the
Philippines when the new hundred dollar
bills were issued that have the like
little blue shiny thing people didn't
like them and people were like no I
won't trade my old hundred dollar bill
for your new hundred dollar bill I don't
trust this new one eventually they got
used to it but there's there's things
that even money can be not fungible but
so the classic example is like okay gold
is fungible diamonds are not diamonds I
have little experience with diamonds
they seem kind of silly but like they're
all unique right they've got different
grades and different cuts and different
sizes and carrots and little inclusions
and imperfections and you've got this
whole industry where you know people
with these little eye things like look
at the diamonds and figure out oh this
is a good one or this one so so whereas
gold is well sort of also has essayists
and good delivery standards and all
these things for the gold bars but it's
much more of a standard and there's no
judgment call it's like okay this is
gold
it's 99.95% pure its weighs this much
this is how much it's worth and you can
chop gold up and okay sorry divisibility
is different than fungibility right so
if diamonds were all identical but not
divisible they could still maybe
function as money you just need a lot of
little diamonds but the fact that Gold's
also divisible is really is
but the fungibility is really what's
nice about it and what makes it sort of
used as money currencies fungibility is
actually I'm not a lawyer but I hang out
with them it's it's enforced by the law
itself so it's an interesting case
Crawford versus the Royal Bank in
Scotland a couple hundred years ago
where there was a guy and he wrote his
name on a twenty pound to note it's like
Crawford you know this is his money and
I think he was trying to mail it someone
he lost it years later the note shows up
at a bank and he's like no see that was
my money and I lost it
and he demands the money back right i I
lost that money this is my property give
it back it's got my name on it I can
prove it and then the court says no no
that's not how money works right the
bank has the money you can't you can't
just write your name on money and then
have it be yours because you know and
and this is this is very different from
property right so if you steal a bicycle
and then you go sell it on well sorry if
someone steals a bicycle sells it on
Craigslist and you buy it and you didn't
know right it's just whatever some guys
selling a bike on Craigslist the police
show up and say hey that bicycle stolen
we're taking it back and you're like
well I didn't know you know I just
bought on Craigslist I paid a couple
hundred bucks police are like sorry
we're taking you no you're not you're
not in trouble right we're not gonna
charge you with a crime but this these
are stolen goods we're taking them back
giving it to the rightful one owner and
that's how the law works you're not if
you can try to complain about it but
they're taking it money's different
right if you're running a pizza store
someone comes in gives you a 20 by so
pizza and then presumably eats it or
whatever and then a couple hours later
the police come in and say hey that guy
stole that 20 dollar bill and we're
taking it back and giving it to its
rightful owner as the shopkeeper like
well which I don't even know which 20
dollar bill even though they're serial
numbers and the police could say no it
was this twenty dollar bill we're taking
it back returning it to the person he
stole it from legally they can't do that
right I'm
[Music]
but so this is from talking to lawyer
people so so money's different money's
not property in the same sense and and
the fungibility is enforced by the state
and it's also enforced the divisibility
and fungibility are enforced by the
banks and that like the the US dollar
isn't like worth anything in that the
government and the banks don't have to
give you anything for a dollar like they
used to sort of have this agreement
where okay you give us was it twenty
five thirty five dollars and we'll give
you an ounce of gold that the government
no longer is in place but they do have
to give you change
right so they do have a duty where if
you have a bunch of old beat-up 20
dollar bills the bank sort of does have
to honor those and give you new $20
bills and that's one of the things that
the Bureau of Engraving and printing and
the Fed they all have this system so
they maintain the currency in that
system in that sense so there's all
these things that like you don't really
think about in that how money operates
but fungibility divisibility those are
like really important and most of it is
enforced by the legal system Bitcoin
does not have these legal protections
you want you want Bitcoin to work even
where it's not legally recognized as
being money and our goal is to make it
like money so yeah if they're stolen
bitcoins and you can trace them the you
know law enforcement could say no those
bitcoins are stolen were recovering them
so it's it's not treated as a currency
it's also not contribute as fungible
right so so in the in the absence of
these sort of protections from the legal
system the software needs to help
enforce the fungibility and divisibility
of these things right so you can sort of
treat the Bitcoin software and rule set
as a sort of only it's not a legal
system but it's a system of rules that
governs how the Bitcoin transactions
work and so the fungibility is has got
to be in the system right so simple so
gold for example they don't have oh they
might I don't want to say they don't
have rules about gold there's probably
all sorts of old laws about gold but uh
but you don't really need a law
enforcing the fungibility of gold in
that you can sort of melt it down and
it's untraceable right if you you have
this old gold coin from this Empire and
this other
from this empire you melt the gold you
put it into a new coin no one can tell
so so similarly Bitcoin needs to enforce
punch ability that way okay so any
questions so far about these definitions
or objections I don't think Bitcoin
should be fungible they're not they're
not valued the same because they haven't
been fully confirmed yeah no that's an
interesting way to look at it I mean I'm
not talking about sort of the time-based
things here because I guess in in many
cases you say okay I'm gonna weigh today
and if it's got a hundred confirmations
it's good right I'll consider it fully
value but yeah there could be things
where you look at the probability of a
double spend and then sort of assigned
value to it increasing as time passes or
something that's sort of a unique thing
to Bitcoin where the transfers the the
sort of finality of the transfer
increases with time which is not really
the case with like gold or dollars we're
like okay I got it
like the fact that I've had it for one
minute or 10 minutes doesn't really
change that I've got it so so yeah that
that's that's an interesting point um
not really addressing it here I'm sort
of you know in this in this conversation
just assume you wait a day and then all
the the probability of it going back is
sort of negligible but it's more the
fungibility in that like you can trace
where it came from and you know assign
values to different coins based on that
so there's a real-world example of this
I don't want to name specific names but
customer buy some coins you go to
exchange you send them a couple hundred
bucks you say I want to buy some
bitcoins and the customer buy the buys
the bitcoins and then transfers the
coins to a betting shop a betting
company in the UK
and bets on a soccer game for example
any wins great so he you know bought a
coin sent it over to this UK gambling
company bet on a soccer game or a
football I guess they call it wins now
he has two coins transfers those two
coins back to the u.s. exchange and he
wants to sell them before he can click
sell his account is closed and the
exchange website says nope you violated
our Terms of Service we're closing your
account you know take your bitcoins take
me we've sent all your dollars back to
your bank you know withdraw your
bitcoins we're out this happens so this
is it Rob I mean whether you agree with
gambling being legal you know so in the
UK Harvard there's no law violated right
and as a United States so this is sort
of a gray area I'm pretty sure that if
I'm a US citizen I take a plane over to
London I go to a I don't know the lingo
punters shop betting shop yeah there's
also and then I bet on something and I
win well I'm pretty sure I have to you
have to pay capital gains on those
winnings to the US IRS but I haven't
broken a law right because I'm not in
the US when I'm doing this thing so
similarly how you know if casino
gambling is illegal in Massachusetts
sort of I can go to Las Vegas I can
gamble and I can come back to the
Massachusetts and it's okay so this is
probably a gray area I don't know if
there's actual court cases about this
where you're still sitting in
Massachusetts at your computer but
you've sent your money to the United
Kingdom you I don't know I don't I don't
think I don't know of anyone who's
gotten in trouble for this I don't know
if there's been prosecution like against
UK betting shops for this kind of thing
but this happens a lot of a lot of
companies run betting shops like this
but I have seen that US exchanges will
shut down accounts because of this they
say look you can buy bitcoins but if
you're using these to gamble we don't we
want to get involved it's just more risk
for us and so they close their accounts
so the problem here is what did I say
next
yeah what's from from the perspective of
like the legal system for
user it's obviously problems because
it's annoying what's the problem for
Bitcoin here why should care about this
back but yeah the real thing is these
two bitcoins are sort of worth less than
two other bitcoins right now you've got
a sort of different value for these
where these two bitcoins are hot and I
need to you know get rid of them and
launder them or something right and you
just walk to the Bank of America and say
here I want to deposit this probably
you've got some problems okay actual
physical currency notes so yeah so this
now now you've got the sort of money
laundering that now people are gonna try
to do using Bitcoin it'd be preferable
if it was so the the way that they can
tell about this is that people reuse a
dresses Bitcoin is not inherently as
fungible as say gold or or even dollar
but dollar bills have these serial
numbers right and I don't know to what
extent people tracked these things but
bitcoins are much more like the dollar
bills with serial numbers and it's all
on on the internet it's all on the
computer so it's really easy to track
things this way
and no one could stop him yes or no
right so you say okay the bitcoins are
you know I'm at the exchange they've got
a giant pool of addresses I transfer to
you know the the casino and then the
casino in this in many of these cases
uses reuses addresses extensively so
it's really easy to see that this is the
casino and then from the casino goes to
the exchange again exchange flags that
and says hey no we know where this came
from instead you say okay I go to user a
and then I go to the exchange in some
cases that might you know if there
algorithm is hey just look at where it
came from
sure but if you say wait there was one
output
you know this transaction is one input
one output so we know exactly where it
came from you can trace it back that way
so it depends the coins being worth less
you know this is unmown alike and since
legal tender is a whole other thing and
I'm pretty sure a Bitcoin will never be
legal tender anywhere in terms of like
that's gonna be settled it but at least
fungibility we want that so if we want
to make Bitcoin more money like how do
we fix this
the first and and simplest and possibly
the biggest is address reuse so if the
casino keeps using the same address over
and over it's really obvious and so
things like vanity addresses so a lot of
them will use vanity addresses a vanity
address is when you continually perform
computations to try to get a human
readable address right the addresses are
random numbers though for example I
taint rich so Greg Maxwell has this
address which is 1g Maxwell boa MD
accident so you can see that the first
you know the first part of that address
is to you Maxwell and you get that just
by continually attempting millions and
millions or billions of different keys
and seeing which turn into the address
you want so people do that people spend
a lot of resources on making cool
addresses and then the casino can say
okay this is my address but that really
hurts the fungibility and privacy
because now it's clear what when you
know I want a customer sends to that
address every
one in the world can see its breathing
you know but yeah like Satoshi dice does
this too right or did one yeah so these
social Satoshi dice addresses Satoshi
dry spinning yeah it always starts with
one dice nine in one day yeah so like
branding I guess makes it easier for it
does make it easier for people to
recognize and if they have a list of the
addresses they're like oh that's the
casino dress I want to deposit to the
casino and just copy and paste that in
there so so like it is a use it it does
help usability and that's one of the
issues in Bitcoin it's like having these
giant ugly addresses that you have to
get right and not sent to the wrong one
it's it's not a great user experience
kind of thing so I can see that vanity
addresses do improve improve the user
experience a little bit but it really
hurts the privacy of the system so an
address race is a problem because people
keep using it it looks cool also web
explorers in for scoops a lot like so if
you look at um you know if you just look
at blockchain on info right you'll have
it
this is Advanced Mode enable disable I
don't know
even with Advanced Mode yeah okay it'll
it'll give you a link to the output so
no one's gonna click that anyway so the
idea is this shows
oh here's the transaction it's coming
from two addresses sending to two
addresses and it even gives you a
helpful hey this is this is greg maxwell
right and i'll give you a link to where
does this go you're being redirected
okay well go for it
GMAX okay so it's Greg's
Gregg's little account on Bitcoin talk
interesting but so this is you know you
guys know enough about this system now
that this is not true right if you click
on an address and now it gives you all
the transactions way too many that were
involved in this but if you if you click
on a transaction it's it's not spending
from addresses in to addresses its
spending from transaction outputs and
spending to addresses that can later be
consumed so the way that web explores
and it'll show a balance right if I
clicked on an address it says hey here's
the number of transactions involved
here's the final balance you know and
you can look at the current balance and
things like that but that's not actually
how the system works and it hurts hurts
privacy and fungibility to have this
idea of oh this is sort of my account
and it's got a balance that can increase
and decrease because then that implies
that I'm gonna keep using it whereas
really they if they're one-time use that
hurts that really makes it harder to
trace things okay so another aspect that
hurts this if you want to trace things
so if it's one input one output right
here it's real easy but even if it's not
one input one output so for example
imagine a transaction where the input
has ten coins in it there's output a
which is one coin output B which is
eight point nine nine seven nine nine
seven coins which do you think is the
change address right there all different
addresses but the eight point nine seven
right I mean it's it's okay he's you
know whoever's doing this they're
sending one coin and the remainder minus
the fee is this so it's often pretty
clear even though looking at it all the
addresses are different okay is it are
any of these change the dresses is it
just a sending to B and C is it a
sending to B and back to a I'll often
it's pretty easy to figure out and
you're guessing but you can get the
guessing pretty pretty good okay so what
we're gonna talk about now anonymity
sense so bitcoin is not actually
anonymous right there are sort of
identities attached to these things in
it you have addresses the addresses are
not your name but you can think of them
as a pseudonym right and you can
create a bunch of pseudonyms but they
there are these keys there are these
publicly seen you know known addresses
and so we want to expand an anonymity
set and so the idea of annum anonymity
set is how many possible different you
know identities could be the owner of
these coins so and the idea of expanding
your anonymity set so even if Bitcoin
were perfectly anonymous in terms of the
anonymity set was everyone who had
Bitcoin that's still actually not that
many people so if you see a Bitcoin
you're like well I don't know who owns
it but I know that the person who owns
it owns Bitcoin and actually there's not
that many people who own Bitcoin so I've
just eliminated 99% of the people my
suspects right just just by doing that
so just having more people using Bitcoin
makes it more anonymous in that sense
right if it's very niche kind of thing
and then the police say okay well
whoever did this crime they're a Bitcoin
user
well now you can find there's not that
many Bitcoin users so you want to try to
increase your anonymity set for a
specific transaction okay so the
traditional I don't want to say
traditional the way you do this is
basically monitoring laundering it's a
Bitcoin mixer and these mixers still
exist I'm pretty sure right James you
know they're still around they're still
around I don't know why but a lot of
times these tor well I mean I know why
but it's like there's so many better
ways to do this so you've got coins that
address a and you say okay I'm gonna
send ten coins to the mixer which does
address B and then later some different
not from that output but somewhere else
in this sort of giant mixer account for
coins get sent to address C and for
coins six going to address D so you've
now expect you know you basically pool
all the coins into this mixer which uses
lots of different addresses and then
split it up over time different amounts
and it gets really hard to figure out
where the coins came from so you're in
and we said is bigger the the problem is
mixers work well potential a nativity
set is all the other users of the mixer
if it's well designed the problem the
mixer is a sphere with everyone's money
very consistently the mixers are not
certainly not publicly regulated company
I'm pretty sure you couldn't do that so
they're just sort of these anonymous
like hey I'm a mixer Bitcoin cloud or
Bitcoin fog or whatever and the a lot of
times they're on tour so you don't even
know where the mixer exists and you just
sort of hope for the best and send your
money in yeah yeah some of them take
these the big fee is when they keep all
your money and don't give it back but
but yeah a lot of times they will take a
small small cut but it's it's not
actually hard to write the cost is
pretty minimal in that you you need some
kind of tour service and then you just
have some software that just runs this
and you know allows deposits and
withdrawals the conference in Puerto
Rico financial crypto so there was a
talk about a what was the word they used
not traceable a reputable a mixer that
you could prove defrauded you right so
you had you know you could you could
have these proofs that like oh I can
prove that they stole my coins that I
which is I don't know I thought was kind
of useless because the whole idea is
they're anonymous and maybe you can
prove that they ripped you off but they
still ripped you off okay so then the
better idea than a mixer is I taint rich
was a blog post from Greg that's why
I've got this up in 2013 it was kind of
fun ever since I was a wee lad I had a
dream my dream being incorrectly acestus
and possibly rich by brain-dead
automated analysis now with your help I
can be so he wanted to mix inputs from
different people within the same
transaction so you could have two
different people in the same transaction
and in Bitcoin this is secure because
the signature signs the whole
transaction so you say okay I'm user a I
put you know have my 10 coin input I'll
match up with user B who's got his to
coin input and we both signed this whole
transaction which sends two points to C
and ten coins to D so now you can't
trace where these coins went right well
sort of can but but it's but if you just
look at the graph of transactions it's
not as obvious so the first transactions
really
fun I remember seeing this so there's
there's three inputs 40,000 bitcoins
0.133 seven bitcoins and one Bitcoin
from Gregg's and then 40,000 and three
one three three and then 0.82 for some
reason it was even more like yeah 40,000
bitcoins is pretty good today it was no
less impressive at the time in 2013 even
though I guess it was only worth about
half a million dollars at that time but
but it was like it was pretty cool and
then Gregg was like wow I've never seen
that much money wait where did ya loaded
so the guy who posted the 40 thousand
coins he's called loaded and nobody
knows who he is but he shows up from
time to time and has a lot of money and
so yeah then Gregg you know made a
transaction uploaded I've handled prices
before the most I've ever moved how to
move on a single key press so very cool
so it's pretty cool you can now you know
you can put this was very manual right
that was on a message board sort of
goofing around but there's no risk
you're not sending money to someone and
then getting it back you're just saying
oh Moo you know I'll sign off on this
transaction and them transactions are
atomic right you can't say oh I'm gonna
cut off this bottom part and only have
ten coins go in and two coins come out
right the whole transaction is the thing
that gets signed okay so what's the
problem with this model anyway to tell
any way to get a mapping from C and D to
a and B there's one really obvious one
on this great it's an X right yeah well
gee I think it's a goes to D and B goes
to C because the amounts are completely
different and actually we'll talk about
amounts next week but yeah so how about
this well you've got ten coins coming in
two coins coming in here here and I've
got address CDV enough one seven one and
three better maybe no no nice right you
can still easily write the seven goes to
the ten the you know seven three the one
and one there's no
I don't think there's any way it could
be anything else yeah how about this
address cs2 coins address ds2 coins
address he has eight points
well now that actually works right it's
not clear if C is from A or B same with
D right these two have some anonymity in
that you're not sure which of which user
it's from he on the other hand is
obviously for me but these coins are now
sort of in deterring you know the
anonymity set has gone has doubled right
you don't know whether it's C or D right
these addresses now unclear so that's
kind of cool how do we you know scale
this well have more users and a bigger
anonymity set so one issue with this is
the users them as you scale to more
users let's say you do ten different
users where they all put in their inputs
they all put in their set of outputs and
now you've got this big transaction
where they can sort of it's hard to tell
what the mapping is the promise you gain
numbers of inputs and numbers of users
the users themselves know the mapping
right because someone's actually doing
the you know I put in my thing and put
in yours so there's a user that knows
the mapping and they can leak that info
and that hurts the enemy right so maybe
just hurting just the transaction graph
itself won't tell you but somebody knows
and they can reveal that at a later date
so that's not good so there's a really
cool really cool protocol called coin
shuffle so pre coin join messaging to
shuffle the inputs and outputs and this
allows you to have ten twenty thirty
different people doing it and if least
if at least two participants are honest
then the mapping cannot be determined
the way it works like this is super
quick because I don't have time that
everyone has their inputs right that
they want to put into the transaction
and they also have the output addresses
that they want as their outputs so they
they make a new set of public keys that
they're not going to use on Bitcoin at
all right they're just making public
keys for encryption purposes for this
this game and they also tell everyone
here's my inputs right
my input is a my input is B so the
inputs are publicly known or not
publicly pumped to the people
participating and then the idea is okay
I know everyone's public key that
they've given so I encrypt my output so
I've got an input I told everyone I've
got my output and I encrypt that the
address itself and the amount with
everyone's public keys sequentially so
for example I use encryption you know
encryption on key C to encrypt the thing
on encryption on key B encrypt the
encryption on PA of my output and then I
hand this to user a okay so this is like
Onion Routing sort of onion encryption
where you take a plaintext encrypt it
encrypt it again and encrypt it again
so I receive these encrypted outputs I
shuffle them write I received one from a
1 from B 1 from C you know I receive
Eric's actually I received the whole set
I shuffle the order and then I put use
my key to decrypt one layer right it's
still gonna be encrypted because I just
see here's a bunch of encrypted data i
decrypt it it's still encrypted with the
next person's key and then I hand it to
them and they shuffle decrypt so the
final user gets the outputs and you know
the final user so in this case user C
can decrypt and now he's got my output
but it's annulled around with everyone
else's output at every step of the way
so they can't tell whose went to whom
and then they have this final
transaction which has all the outputs in
some random order because everyone
contributed to randomizing the order of
the outputs so this is really cool as
long as two parties are honest if
there's only one honest party it doesn't
work because then every dishonest party
colludes and says well you know we know
everything but the honest parties output
so we can figure out which one it is but
if there's two users then you can't
determine two users actually doing this
then you can't determine the order so
that's pretty cool I think it's being
used for join market thank you something
like this I don't know so there's like
cool techniques for this kind of thing
okay real-world though some people use
this right join market exists
I don't know how popular it is problem
which people use this who uses this it's
got a limited anonymity set of the
people who really want anonymity which
is not the anonymity set the people who
want in any buddy want it's just kind of
confusing but the idea is I don't want
to just be in this group of people who
want anonymity because those are the
people I don't want to be associated
I would rather associate myself with the
people who don't particularly want
anonymity this is a big problem right
how do you people don't want if you
people don't care about privacy people
don't want to do these kinds of things
and and this costs money too in this
case like if you're doing these
transactions this isn't really a payment
this is just a superfluous transaction
to turn your money around to get some
more privacy this is one of the big
issues with okay we want anonymity but
if it if anonymity is opt-in it's not
very useful right because then it's it's
sort of like tor where if I'm using tor
everyone's like why are you using tor
and and so yeah well at this point
encryption is now sort of ubiquitous and
it's like the standard but yeah most
trends are actual Bitcoin transactions
are ending up from exchanges I don't
know there's a lot but I don't know if
it's majority I think it's I think it's
like a decent percentage but I think
it's less than half but yeah there's a
lot
it's it'd be awesome so exchanges are
actually uniquely positioned where
something like coin shuffle you could
really easily do a like oblivious
withdrawal where you say I want to
withdraw my coins and I'm not gonna tell
you where to but I'll give you this
encrypted thing that gets shuffled
around with different users and then at
the end I sign off on it and the
exchange can say well we're fulfilling
all our customers withdrawals but we
don't know where
the coins are going you could totally do
that I that's not a conversation that
happens at any exchange here's this you
know users name and address you know his
house home address and his social
security number
and here's what he bought and sold
versus does that also have and here's
where the addresses where he withdrew
his coins to that you know I don't I
don't think the IRA like the IRS thing I
think it was mostly we want to get
people for not reporting their games I
don't think it was right FinCEN the to
map Bitcoin addresses to human names so
they could see who did what
I don't yeah IRS just wants to know who
sold and didn't report gates by the way
next to this weekend if you sold any
coins last year you gotta tell the IRS
I'm actually gonna pay a little bit of
tax on that so yeah so so in anybody's
tricky yeah like you could try to go
through exchanges probably not the best
it's just not like they're not gonna do
it it's it's hard to do even research on
this kind of stuff when you're a company
there's a lot of sort of chilling
effects itself that's sort of why I like
working at MIT in that if I want to
research crazy anonymity stuff totally
fine whereas if I'm working at a VC
funded company in San Francisco and I'm
like hey we're making you know these
anonymity protocols you sure you want to
do it like it could be an awkward
conversation in some cases okay so yeah
people don't care about privacy it's
sort of an externality if you say well
I'm using addresses but that only hurts
my privacy that's naturally not true
right in the simplest sense
you're reducing the anonymity set for
everyone else right so if I have point
you know if I say okay where are James's
coins well I know they're not at 1g
Maxwell 909 because that's Greg
Maxwell's coins so it can't so I'm you
know when you use publicly identifiable
addresses and vanity addresses you're
actually reducing the anonymity set for
everyone else it's sort of an
externality where the people who say I
don't care about privacy are not paying
the cost of harming the people who don't
care about privacy so this is a tricky
problem and the solution it's there's no
solution but one one cool thing one way
forward is well everyone likes cheaper
transactions right everyone likes saving
one so can we make it cheaper to improve
in an image and so privacy and
scalability in some cases are at odds
right so in things like ring signatures
which is maybe I'll I don't think I have
time to go but but Monaro is a sort of
privacy focused currency that uses ring
signatures where you can point to a ring
signatures I can point to two public
keys and say okay there's public key a
in public he be I'm signing message m on
one of those two public keys but I'm not
telling you which and you can verify
that okay one of these keys signed but I
you know I don't know which and the
signer had to have one of the private
keys or both right it's easy to if you
have both keys you can obviously make a
ring signature and it doesn't have to be
two it can be five ten whatever a bunch
of you know you pick a bunch of public
keys sign with one of them so that's
pretty cool that expands the size of
signatures I believe with like o of n so
if I have ten keys you're pointing to
and you make a signature on one of them
the signature actually gets bigger and
so there's so like for Manero they use
all these different systems and
scalability is one of the big problems
with there I mean it's a problem with
Bitcoin as well it's problem with
everything but it's it's even worse in
manera because of the choices and like
the different algorithms they use so in
some cases privacy and scalability
scalability are at odds but in some
cases it works together where you can
say look we just we want to have less
information about these transactions so
if you have left's information to store
theirs
information to link the users to their
coins okay so an idea here is aggregate
signatures so currently when you sign
you have this input you say okay here's
users a signature here's users B
signature and you're doing this like
ineffective coin joint thing here the
goal would be we want to aggregate these
signatures so we don't have a signature
for this input we just have a single
signature on key C which is just somehow
the combination of a and B's signature
and then you can save space because
there's only one signature that stays
the same size but still prove that both
a so this is not a ring signature right
this is aggregate is a and B both signed
and produced a single signature together
and that can validate the whole thing
okay so how can we make this signature
we know pump Keys a and B they're both
signing the same message which is really
important there's other the terms for
these things there's like multi
signatures aggregate signatures key
aggregation like and no one agrees on
I've had arguments like I've had
discussions with people and I'm like
wait that's what you call it I was
calling it something else and there's
not really good terms for this but in
this case what we want is we're signing
the same message so that makes it easier
right we're not we're not trying to
combine different messages different
signatures on different messages from
different pub keys and combine it to the
same signature that's even harder
although that is possible in some some
ways but in this case a and B are
signing the same message with they're
two different keys and they need one
signature and the signature is going to
be RNs right so the equation that we had
that we've done a couple times you know
the signature is K some random number
minus the hash of the message and K
times G R times the private key and to
verify you you know R minus the hash of
the message in R times the public key
now
if you share the private keys with each
other it's kind of easy right you say
hey Alice just says here's my key Bob
and then the Bob can compute everything
you can do that was ECDSA but you really
don't want to share private keys because
as soon as you give someone else your
private key maybe they don't sign this
aggregate signature of the thing you
want to sign they sign something else
giving them all the money so you want to
be involved in this process okay so the
simplest sort of multi signature system
for signatures first you want to share
an R value but so this this R is also
gonna have to have contributions from
both users right who comes up with what
here if C is the combination of both
Alice and Bob's public key well the
message we have already agreed on but
this R value is the question so the idea
is Alice comes up with k sub a computes
R sub a and gives it to Bob Bob makes K
sub B computes R sub B and gives that to
Alice then both of them can say okay
well we know the real r that we're gonna
use for the signature is the sum of R
sub a and R sub B then they want to
compute their own SS I don't know how to
ask
so for Alice S sub a is gonna be equal
to K sub a that only she knows right she
shared R sub a but not case of a with
Bob - the hash of the message and this
aggregate you know the summed R times
her private key for Bob its SMB equals
case of me - the hash of the message in
our times little B and then they give
each other or really only one party
needs to do this right either Alice
gives S sub a to Bob or Bob gives s sub
a to Alice but they don't have to both
do it because then the final step is you
just add the SS right so this sum you
know this aggregate s is s ma + s sub B
which is case of a plus K sub B - the
hash of M + R times a - the hash of M +
R times B which is you can call this K
right that's the discrete log of R
because they summed it and then you can
factor out the a and B here and so this
is the sum of their private keys this is
the sum of their K values and then the
signal verification step will work and
that works awesome okay questions about
this basic basically makes sense there's
all sorts of minefield caveat sort of
watch out things for example if they
learn your K value they will learn your
private key once they get us
normally you make normally you make
deterministic K values where you compute
K as like the hash of your message being
signed and your private key that's
dangerous to do in this case because
they might get a K value from you and
then get and then give you a different R
value and get another K value and like
find your private key so there's all
sorts of like watch out things okay so
the the idea is okay now cool
we've got address you know we've got
output which needs a signature from a
we've got an output which needs a
signature from B we'll use those as
inputs and just have this sum C
signature and that shows that both
parties signed right so we're good now
we have way less data right these
signatures are like 60 something 65
bytes so instead of having it twice you
just have one that covers the whole
transaction great and it can it doesn't
have to be a it doesn't have to be two
right you can see how this would extend
to three four or five different people
they would all have to compute their own
K value give it to everyone else
everyone compute computes this combined
R value and then does their own s's and
then sums them all up and this would
work with any number of participants
problem you've got a bunch of coins that
40,000 coins from before and then one
day you see wait I'm user a user beam
came up with a user a and B signature
and sent it all to address
II I never signed anything I didn't do
this process with him how did he steal
all my coins this is bad so any idea of
how you could do this with the equations
we okay so what you do is you say hey
here's key a on the network and and
normally you see pub key hashes but a
lot of times you see pub keys and anyway
you definitely see the pub key once
people try to spend it so maybe if you
maybe you have to do this quickly but
you can do this real quick so you say
okay I'm gonna make you a random you
know a random private key compute Q
times G to be big Q and then I'll
compute key B which is Q minus a and
then I will send some coins to be and
now note that I don't know the private
key for B write the private key for B is
gonna be this little Q minus little a I
don't know a little a so I don't know
what little B is but that's okay so it's
I don't I don't send too many coins to
key B and anyway I'll get him back
I don't know B I can't sign with it
however I want to spend from B and a
together I don't know little B I don't
little away I don't know the private key
for either but I do know the private key
for both which is sort of confusing but
the idea is well C is gonna be a plus B
which is a plus Q minus a which is just
Q right so in this case I can observe a
key find you know make this rogue key
and then spend from both of them without
knowing the actual key that I I wanted
to steal from so this is a huge problem
right you can't have this this would
make signature aggregation completely
insecure what are some ideas of how to
how to fix that
any so the interesting thing is in all
the literature about multi signature
this problem sort of still persists and
the new reason the new papers about how
to use this in Bitcoin are the ones that
are actually addressing it so the
general idea was well make B sign right
make B prove that he actually can sign
with with key B before you start doing
these
have Alice and Bob talk to each other
and Bob says okay here's a signature
with with key B and al says okay here's
the signature with key a and now you've
proven that that they actually can sign
and they're not doing these kinds of
rogue attacks right so that's the
straight straightforward way to do it
right we're okay
you know if you don't know B and can't
sign we're not going to continue with
this process that's interactive though
so yeah make me sign a message before
combining keys easy that's what people
sort of thought about for years but the
whole point here is to aggregate
signatures and so if you require B to
create a signature and post it into the
transaction you've just eliminated all
the games all the space-saving for this
technique so we can't have that we want
it to be non interactive we want any
existing keys to be usable in this
system without free committing to
anything you could also make it
interactive where well anyway it's
actually the better way to do it
ud linearize the signatures so you
redefine the signatures you still send
to for example key a or key B you know
your outputs are still pump keys but
when you require a signature you don't
require a signature from that pub key
you you require a signature from that
pub key times the hash of that pump key
right so you say okay I'm sending to any
but when normally I have Sig a saying
you know signature from key a instead I
say no I want a signature from a time's
the hash of a this is so anyone who
knows the private key for a will know
the private key for this because this is
public right everyone can see what the
hash of a is and then so it's just
little a times hash of little a right
you just multiple you know this is a
scalar multiplication so the scalar
multiplication works the same for the
mean sorry this is the you know the
point multiplication and it works the
same for the scalar down here so this is
it doesn't hurt it doesn't make it any
harder to sign you just have to perform
a hash operation and a multiplication
which is quick but what it does
is it prevents this kind of attack so
instead of signing with a plus B sign
with a times the hash of a plus B times
the hash of B since in this case in
Bitcoin the public key is that you know
you know you can see what public keys
are being signed and aggregated so you
say okay well I'm gonna try to do this
technique C is a times the hash of a
plus B times the hash of B the private
key is gonna be a times the hash of the
pump QA plus little B times the hash of
punky Big B I know B which is Q minus a
or sorry I don't
well I compute it I don't know B this is
I know Q right and I I constructed sort
of this B is Q minus a but I don't know
it so C is now going to be a times the
hash of a plus Q minus a times the hash
of Q minus a right that's what B is I
can't cancel out this little a anymore
right because it's got a different
coefficient maybe it's easier if you
sort of move them on the other side
right I've now got these coefficients in
front of my private keys that are not
the same and won't cancel out anymore
before if the code you know I sue before
it's the same like before the system is
x one right so the idea was a times 1
plus Q minus a times 1 since the
coefficients are the same one I can
factor them out and now you know apply
these and remove the a so if the
coefficients are the same if it moves it
was a times the hash of a plus Q minus a
times the hash of a I'm good
I can still factor out that coefficient
and cancel out a but now the
coefficients are different and so I
can't do that subtraction right and now
I'm stuck I cannot sign with this little
C just from knowing Q questions about
this yeah
Oh everything there is in this attack Q
is just any random number right but the
idea is here Q being any random number
doesn't help you right because you
you've sent money to be you're trying to
sign from you're trying to sign with Q
minus a but you don't actually know the
private key q minus a so you're stuck I
mean even even if you did in this case
it wouldn't help right because you still
have that a there so this prevents that
kind of straightforward you know so your
attack can't get rid of the a times H a
term this actually is not enough there's
a paper called Wagner Wagner's paper
some guy in California UC Berkeley I
think a generalized birthday problem and
it's a hard paper to read but if you're
working on these kinds of things it's a
good paper to read because it comes up
again and again with these kinds of
attacks collisions did we talk about I
don't think we ever talked about okay so
the idea of colliding for example a hash
function or in this case public heat
usually it takes half this the work that
you the reason it's called like a
birthday paradox is because what's do
people know this birthday thing like how
many people need to be in a room before
two people have the same birthday and
it's like 22 or something it's like
really low and and it's surprising
because you'd think well maybe 365
divided by 2 so like a hundred something
you know 180 or something but it's
actually 22 I think because of the way
like for every new person added there's
a possibility they collide with every
already existing person's birthday and
so the collisions are like more common
than you think
so in the case of colliding a hash
function even though if even if the hash
function is 2 to the 256 bits you only
need two to the 128 attempts to collide
and find two that are there that are the
same and that's if you store all the old
hashes and so
I keep coming up with new ones after the
square root of the number of attempts
you'll find it and then there's some
techniques with like cycle finding where
you don't have to store them all things
like that so usually you think ok 2 to
the N over 2 time to find a collision
but that's a collision between two
things and Wagner's attack is sort of
yeah find a and B such that a equals B
kind of the normal vision now find a0 a1
up to a I so find I things on this side
and J things on this side such as the
sum of a equals the sum of B and in the
case of elliptic curve points it would
actually be the sum you do addition in
the case of hashes it might be X or or
some other operation but the idea is if
you have a lot of different things and
you can pick and choose on both sides
you can potentially find collisions when
what much less time and in the case of
these elliptic curve points it probably
would be practical you'd need I don't
know
dozens 20 30 40 different keys but you
could potentially say ok there's a key
with a lot of coins I'm going to find a
whole bunch a set of a whole bunch of
keys such that that I can cancel that
key out even with this multiplying by a
different coefficient because I've got
like so many you know so much search
space III can't like it's a kind of kind
of it's a cool paper you should look
through it if you're interested but
that's a problem you can you can sort of
make progress is the basic idea is that
I can keep getting closer and closer to
canceling this thing out so instead we
have these improved D linearization and
this is talked about in the music paper
or from like January you take the hash
of all the keys concatenated together in
some specified order all right so you
sort the keys some way and you say ok Z
is the hash of a and B or if there's
more keys a and B and C you know just
all concatenated and then you sign with
a time's the hash of Z and a 0 plus B
times the hash of Z and a 1 so you make
the coefficients distinct but you also
make the coefficients
MIT to every single part of the set
right every key in the set needs to be
in this coefficient and the music sort
of explains why that works so the the
attack right in in this case is well
I've got these different coefficients
right but the coefficient here only
depends on this key here so maybe I can
find a bunch of different keys with
different coefficients such that these
coefficients will cancel out or you know
these coefficients will sum or multiply
you know sum up to hash of a so it seems
like hard right I can't find something I
can't find different hashes that will
equal the hash of a right that's a hash
collision but if I have any number of
different things I may be able to and so
the idea is if you do this well now
every time I'm adding or removing a key
from my attempt I still I have to change
Z so I can't leave this here and start
adding things and try to try to work on
it that way because every time I add of
C or D Z changes and so I have to start
over from scratch
so that's the anyway that's my general
intuition of how the de linearization
works for music and then yeah it used to
be like Z and then put a in here because
now that makes it unique but you can
actually just number them you just need
them to be distinct and since this hash
function just say like 0 1 2 3 4 it's
good enough ok any questions about this
I realize it's kind of complicated and
the software's kind of crazy but but the
idea is that it prevents a bunch of
these attacks so that you can securely
use aggregate signatures questions
hopefully yeah and you wouldn't have to
program it but yeah so what you can do
is you say okay
it saves space right I've got my the the
first use case will be in single wallets
right non-internet it's it's interactive
right so you have to do that thing where
like
up with different K values I share the
different R values I come up with the s
values I add those up sure if it's all
doing it yourself where it's just there
happened to be two different pub keys
that you control both of you can
basically skip all of that and you can
just say no I'm just gonna you know I'm
just gonna add the two points here and
I'll use the same K value you know it's
just me so this happens a lot in Bitcoin
wallets where you're making a
transaction with multiple inputs they're
all controlled by you but you might have
you know two coins here and three coins
there and you want to send someone for
coins so you got to use both of these
inputs currently in Bitcoin you're gonna
have multiple signatures with with this
new signature aggregation you can say
okay I'm picking these two inputs I'm
signing for all of them with a single
signature and in the case of it all
being yours you don't even have to do
you don't even have to do the two
operations and add them right because
you know the whole all the keys so
that's gonna be the first use case and
that's that's much easier to program
because it's all just within the same
computer and this is easy so that's cool
and then a cool use is okay use it with
coin joint where users a B C and D all
contribute you know they all have an
input with hey the same amount of coins
great and they're doing coin shuffle to
shuffle the order of these outputs so
they're they know so a knows Oh mine is
G but I have no idea about EF and H I
don't know I don't know the mapping
other than my own but hey my my output
is in there
cool so whatever everyone else is doing
I don't care but I'm good with this
transaction and they can contribute
their own K value and their own s value
and then finally then you put the
signature at the bottom and it verifies
that all these participants have signed
and this is really nice because it's
smaller right it used to be this would
be what 200 something 250 bytes worth of
signature data and now it's just 65
bytes worth of signature data at the
bottom so you save on fees you save on
space every
like this yeah it's cheaper than a solo
transaction and so that potentially
helps scalability and privacy and that
if people say I want to do something
cheaply I will connect to other people
and aggregate my signature with theirs
and so we save some space and save some
money and maybe I don't really care
about the anonymity thing maybe I'm you
know entering into a transaction and
there's some people doing shady deals in
this transaction but I don't care right
my thing gets in and out and I saved
money so the extension of this would be
what if you had just one giant
transaction in every block which is all
the inputs and all the outputs and
there's a single signature that would be
really cool
we're not work there are techniques to
do that there's so the issue is its
interactive right in that you have to
know about all the other inputs and all
the other outputs so I can't if it were
non interactive then I could say oh well
there's this transaction where D is
sending coins to H and there's also this
other transaction where C sends coins to
G and they've got their own signatures
if I can take those two and you know I'm
not either of these people I didn't do
anything with these signatures but if I
could take those two things and combine
the signature not interactively then I
could just basically take all the
transactions in my men pool squish them
into one transaction with one signature
and put that in my block that would be
really cool but the issue there is one
the signatures have to be interactive
and two they're on different messages
right so in the case of cease sending to
G it's a message of C to G and in D
sending to H it's on that message there
are techniques though so BLS signatures
Bonet Lin Shaham signatures do allow you
to do this
so non-interactive aggregation of the
signatures which would be really cool
because then a block would only need one
signature and in VLS signatures
signatures themselves are a single point
not a point and a scalar so it would
just be 32 bytes well you'd probably use
a different curve
but um you have to but but yeah the idea
of having these tiny signatures that
satisfy proof for the entire set is
really cool so this is yeah this is a
cool idea there's so you're saying there
isn't software you said like or that
it's not on github okay yeah so the idea
is there was a bunch of software for
this that mostly sip so simply or Peter
wool is his name on the Internet is CIPA
and he told me what that stood for and
it was some like super cheesy thing he
made when he was in like middle school
but anyway um he has been working on
this kind of software so has so has
Gregg that guy who you know five years
ago wrote about this stuff and some
other poster a couple of couple people
have been working on this it's not
publicly available code which is kind of
weird but the reason is that they're
working on Schnoor signatures and
aggregation and it was on github in like
a branch of glib SEC P that the repo
they're using it and then all these alt
coins were taking the code and putting
it into their all coins and saying hey
we support our signatures and so for
example the road key attack like it was
the simple version which didn't have
this x the hash of the pub key and and
they were like wait no don't you know
we're working on this software but we
know all of these problems with it
right you can't actually use this for
signature aggregation we're just sort of
playing around and trying different
things and so they actually pulled it
from github and so it's like like I've
seen it like I well that doesn't have
any of this D linearization or the thing
that prevent wagner's attack I like all
of that stuff is not in there
so okay maybe that's a cool attack but
they they were like oh shoot no like it
but it's said in their repo like do not
use this this is research code do not
use this in production there are known
vulnerabilities but people are like
whatever I'm just you know people didn't
care well yeah there's some esoteric
educational durability but I'm gonna
solve that because XYZ so they actually
pulled the code they are working on the
code and I mean the code works it's it's
I've seen it but they are very sort of
like we don't want to put it publicly
until we're sort of saying okay here's
our final version that we want to put in
Bitcoin because they know as soon as
they sort of put it out there for review
all these all coins will take I mean you
you've implemented this in yeah in not
invert quite in a crypto kernel yeah so
and you do use the music okay oh okay
cool
now you know but yeah so there's um you
know they know that people are gonna use
this because it's a cool it's a cool
signature scheme and once you have and
I've talked about this multiple times
before once you have this your signature
equation there's all these other cool
things you can do with your addresses
and things like that and so that's the
idea here is scalability is one that
okay now we can combine things make it
smaller and also we can hopefully help
privacy this way and that people people
who are not particularly concerned with
their anonymity will say yeah I still
want to use it because I say you know I
can save a buck on fees so yeah I'll
join this transaction with a bunch of
other people and then you've got the
people who actually want anonymity are
like great these are exactly the people
I want to be associated with the people
who don't particularly care about
anonymity so seems like a win-win right
now all the software requires a regular
old signature so for example if you have
you know if these are regular if these
are outputs that are currently being
used and you do this I validate the
output one at a time and I say okay I'm
looking at this output you know look
this input there's no signature at all
fail okay the whole transaction fails so
you need a new output type which says
okay I'm using this new aggregate
signature so actually look at all the
inputs don't validate them at all and
just validate at the end at the bottom
so that's gonna be some different code
and you you can't you can't
retroactively lycée okay all the
existing keys we can now spend you know
all the existing outputs we can outspend
with this new signature scheme you can't
really do that so we'll have to make new
addresses and the new addresses will be
BC 1z instead of Q you know new address
type and then we send to that now you're
allowed to spend from it using aggregate
signatures so all that software is
mostly there but it might take a while
for you got to get everyone on board I'm
curious to see what people will complain
about segue saying it was a little bit
more like there's a lot to complain
about even though I don't like parts of
segments not even I there's a lot of
parts I don't like it won't use but um
but this seems like a sort of clear win
where it's like great you can aggregate
signatures do all these cool things I'm
guessing there will be people saying
this is bad and saying like no because
Satoshi's vision is one signature one
input you know a blockchain is a chain a
coin is a chain of signatures and this
coin has no signatures I don't I'm
guessing I don't know what will happen
but or maybe it might be smooth and
everyone started like yeah this is
obviously better great great paper great
math great idea let's get it you know
let's let's all activate it and use
Bitcoin this way who knows so we'll see
it's pretty cool software though and you
can use it in other projects right so
crypto kernels using signatures a
probably a bunch of different coins who
are sort of more agile in that it's
easier to make changes will probably
start using this I don't if they're I'm
still ECDSA though right yeah no one no
one's there's no coins that are actually
implementing this yet sums whenever uses
82 5 509 which is essentially a snorer
signature and there saw and I think
ripple can use
8255 online so there's some different
schemes that are more similar to this
but still don't have the definitions for
aggregation so anyway so this is cool
stuff next time I will talk about the
next one I'm not looking forward to
making slides because it's like a really
complicated one that I don't even
understand like I sort of get it but
it's like wait how okay but how to mix
different amounts right so how to hide
the it so the basic it's you know in
this case hey it's great but in in many
cases you can see right what I said the
reason it doesn't work is because it's
really obvious where the time you babies
do tend to but what if you could hide
the amounts but still enforce that the
amounts were correct so that's the idea
of confidential transactions which we'll
talk about next time and then it leads
to move a Wimble which is even more
complicated and I'll I don't I'm not
gonna promise then I'll explain the
whole thing but I'll touch on the ideas